number four is
right
excuse me members can i suggest that you
actually um nominate the
the chair of the committee would
normally um
chair a subcommittee in these
circumstances
so there's clearly something going on
here can we just pause for a moment
martin
hello martin
okay so cancel pat bone council steve
pickering can you please
nominate a chair for today's meeting
i'll nominate councillors
can we have a second please
yeah all in favor
thank you members welcome to this
meeting of the licensing
and gambling acts subcommittee today we
hear two applications made under the
licensing
act 2003. this meeting is a public
meeting and is being streamed
live to youtube and by the council's
website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purpose of the minutes
can i ask the clock to confirm the
members and officers in attendance for
this meeting
and explain the procedure for the use of
virtual technology
uh thank you chair um the subcommittee
today consists of
councillor heather liggett councillor
pat bone
and um councillor stephen pickering
um the officers present today to support
the subcommittee are kevin chilito
council solicitor kevin rowland
the licensing team leader um shannon
harpen
licensing officer myself david stanton
the clerk to the committee
and alan marr who is facilitating the
meeting
just to remind members to keep their
cameras on and their microphone is muted
unless they wish to speak and i'm going
to start recording now
this meeting is being recorded and this
is being used for the purposes
of the minutes and just a reminder that
this is being streamed live to youtube
thank you chair thank you the procedure
for the hearing will be as
as required in the license act licensing
act 2003
hearing regulations 2005
and will take the form of a discussion
led by the licensing
authority north east derbyshire district
council
members a full copy of the meeting
procedure is enclosed in your agenda
packs
for applicants and those making
representations a full copy of the
procedure was attached
to the invite letter and report sent to
you last week
item two declarations of interest we now
move to the second
item on the agenda do members have any
interest to declare
i do on the second item the shop and i
do know
audrey and ian howarth but not of
personal nature just purely and simply
because we live in the same village
and they walk the dog past my house
thank you thank you
uh matters of urgency the third atom
item is matters of urgency i have no
matters of urgency for today's
meeting item 4a report
of the licensing and enforcement officer
wood seats hall
can i please invite the licensing and
enforcement officer
to represent report number ltl
forward slash zero two forward slash
two zero dash two one forward slash
kr to the subcommittee in respect of the
application forward seats hall
thank you good morning chair good
morning members good morning everybody
else um this first application
is in respect of the long barn barlow
wood seats hall
johnny gate lane barlow drone field it
was received
from north midlands surveys limited
and a copy of that can be found at
appendix one
the application for the premises license
is before
a large um stone-built barn
and caught an adjacent courtyard at the
hall
the applicant seeks the following
licensable activities
which is live music indoors monday to
sunday
8 30 a.m until midnight recorded music
monday to sunday 8 30 until 0100 the
following morning
late night refreshment from 11 p.m
until midnight sale of alcohol on sales
only
from 8 30 till 11 30 and for
opening times from 08 30 until
her 100 hours the following morning
there are also
a number of non-standard timings
so it relates to all the activities that
they've requested
and that's from 08 thursday until over
200 hours the following day
on bank holidays such as christmas eve
new year's eve so patrick's day and
george's day we have received two
representations
in respect of the application
from two neighbors of the long barn
[Music]
the representation center around being
infected by
an increase in the use of the bond
concerns are expressed with regards to
the current
alleged noise issues other concerns are
problems with access in the lane and the
potential destruction of the local
habitat
of those representations are attached to
appendix 2
and appendix 3 for members attention
and chad do you want me to actually read
those out or are you happy that members
have already
read through them in advance of the
hearing
sorry pat and steve are you happy have
you read
read the paperwork or would you like
having to read it out
um okay yes please uh yes i only got it
yesterday so i've tried to read it for
as much as possible but
yeah if we could have a recap that would
be good
kevin thanks chad i'll come on to that
in a second um
there has also been consultation with
the police which resulted in
a change to the operating schedule
within the application that's been
agreed in a bounce between the police
and the applicant and therefore there is
an amended schedule
attached to the um application
for members consideration and the
assumption is
that if the application is granted then
members would look at
attaching the conditions as per the
schedule plus any additional conditions
that they wish to
to add to that option for members
today is to grab the license grant the
license modified to such an
extent as you believe in respect to the
promotion of the licensing objectives
or to refuse the application
and moving on to the
um representations that have been made
to spare with me
second while i get to the right section
of the
report
right so the first representation is
from john
julia and daniel botham um
it's probably going to be as easy for me
to read this out as to try and proceed
regarding the application for the
premises license
we've been the nearest neighbors to nick
and todd woodstock hall
will be affected by an increase in the
use of the premises of the long bar
until about five years ago this was a
very quiet area
we now move next door to
two assumed to be three holiday less
with up to 20 people staying
the long bar is used for weddings and
parties etc
and also as a restaurant at weekends our
home is just 20 meters away from the
long barn
sea vote so live music can be heard
inside the house even with the tv on
also parties can get very noisy with
talking laughing singing shouting
and we do not want to enjoy any more
that we
than we do now johnny gate lane is a
single
track country lane with with very few
passing places
we sometimes find it very difficult to
get in and out when up to 30 cars attend
at various events
we've tolerated a lot up to now and
don't wish to be bad neighbors
but it is affecting our lives and
business farming
i hope you take this into account only
take into account our concerns when
considering this application
there is then a photo of members
attention
and then the second
um representation is from mrs pamela
doncaster and he says i refer to the
application
and wish to make formal as follows
number one
the local environment is very peaceful
and very much
agricultural and should remain that way
the likely incidence of loud music
blaring out until
one and two in the morning would be
detrimental to the environment
the property at which the license is
being stored is no doubt listed
and a bar which is home to much much in
the way of wildlife in particular bats
once again live music and crowds of
people will destroy that habitat
the road leading to the property is a
narrow single lane track
with no formal passing places and being
a dead end
with just only one weight in and one way
out
will not be able to cope with the
lightly increased traffic flow
from our weight to 220 to 107 days a
week
the verges are all high soft grass
mergers which cannot take the punishment
of vehicles travelling in the opposite
directions trying to pass each other
my residence being only one of three
residences on in johnny gate lane
is the only one that will be affected by
the increase in moving traffic
likely to be at speeds in excess of the
capabilities of the lane and the road
surface
which is in a poor state johnny gate
lane
is popular with walkers cyclists and
horse riders
sometimes in numbers with numerous
footpaths and bridleways feeding into it
the increased traffic flow
will be hazardous to those enjoying the
peace and track
tranquility of that rural lane
yeah thank you very much
uh do members have any questions to ask
the lies and the license
singing for ultimate officer
council pickering thank you chair
um i'd just like to um ask if there's a
description or anybody could give us any
information about
what currently happens in terms of being
a wedding venue and
restaurant the website says that the
website actually says parking for 40
cars the application talks about 30 cars
um so there's obviously potentially more
increased uh
traffic use as some of the uh objectives
have
raised um but i'd just like to know what
currently happens and in terms of uh
drinking and
music and i'm noticing the application
there's an application for dancing i
can't imagine why that
is not at a wedding and where there's
live music or recorded music potentially
until two o'clock in the morning
and people spilling out into the outdoor
area
chair um it may be a better question for
uh council of pickering to ask mr todd
in due course however
from a licensing point of view the
premises have been
operational for a number of years that
i'm aware of
and in the past it has always operated
under temporary event notices
the premises
is at the top of the long lane as as
specified by those making the
representations
um personally i'm not aware of any
complaints being received in the past
about the operation of the premises
and i don't see that there will be any
significant change in what's actually
happening at the premises
compared to what's been happening
previously under the temporary event
notice
but again that might be a question for
mr todd in due course
thank you thank you do those present
homemaking representations have any
questions for the licensing officer
yeah i don't think they're present no
right
uh does the applicant have any questions
to ask the licensing officer
no no right
right thank you uh two representations
were made on this applicant the first
from john and julia and daniel both
the second from mrs pamela doncaster
um they're not present hardly damon
no the notch
in that case we'll move on to his
submissions from the applicants
can i invite mr todd company director of
north midlands
survey limited to make his submissions
please
mr todd
hello mr todd can you hear us
i fear his microphone might have gone
against her
[Music]
mr todd can you
mute your microphone
unfortunately um
hello mr todd can you your microphone
hello mr todd mr todd
can you unmute your microphone
just bear with me mr todd um just one
second
damien is it possible for the house to
mute the microphone
um yeah i've tried that i've tried i
tried to ask him some mute buddies
doesn't seem to be working
um
hello hello hello hello
i'm sorry i'm not sure if i was on mute
there mr todd's having difficulties and
has asked
his architect mr moore to speak on his
behalf if you're comfortable with that
chair
okay okay thank you mr moore
uh thank you sorry i thank you
sorry mister could you turn off your
youtube channel now
i don't have youtube on okay then if
anyone's got youtube on we were
beginning to get that
reverberation again that seems better
now thank you
okay i'm sorry i missed the last minute
or so i was up to date until
uh you asked mr todd to respond so i
should say
my name is philip moore i'm an architect
uh
i've been working on this project for uh
around a year and a half
on behalf of uh the applicant so i know
the history
um i wanted to just sort of give you a
little bit of
i want to give you a little bit of
feedback on um
historically what what you said about
operating undertale is absolutely
correct
sorry i'm hearing feedback myself
hello hello
i think um mr todd has managed to get
his microphone to work
um but where is in control that i don't
know because he keeps going
off can you hear me now
yes um so my name is phillip moore i'm
nick todd's architect
can you hear me yeah that's fine carry
on mr ball
okay so i wanted to respond to
councillor pickering's points
uh just uh point by point if if i may
um you're absolutely correct that the
premises have operated
under tens historically and i think that
having had some experience uh of that um
the applicant decided that really it
wasn't going to be
successful as a venue and a bar
and at that point i was asked to look up
alternative uses following the refusal
uh of the premises as a baron venue uh
but that's that's the refusal under the
planning act
so around a year or so ago um i looked
at the thing afresh and looked at the
reasons for refusal
uh of the of the planning commission for
a bar and
i think that without colored um
the applicant's view as to the fact that
he should
proceed as a restaurant only uh
concentrating on
a higher spend an older age
profile and reduced
hours um obviously shutting
at midnight opening from just before
lunchtime
and also restricting the activities to
pretty much weekend
and of course public holidays and
sundays before bank holidays
which is where the trade is so the
decision was
was made to apply for planning
commission to northeast district council
and so all of the factors such as um
noise car parking habitat
and in particular the use of the use of
the lane and the passing
places which were surveyed by derbyshire
county highways all that was considered
in the planning commission and i would
suggest that the points
that have been raised um are all
planning matters which have
to be for being and gone um derbyshire
county highways have no objection
uh and obviously supported the
application including
um the access including the traffic
issues which
in fact are uh are a downgrade
from the operation and activities under
the
temporary events notices job assure
wildlife trusts have no objections on
habitat grounds
the noise issues which there are
are going to be less because it's going
to be operating more as a restaurant
although i can imagine
at a birthday party there might be
dancing in music
otherwise the music would be background
um and
the noise both in terms of works
physical works and validation are
strictly controlled
under the planning commission which i
can give you the reference number for
but i'm sure
it's accessible to you online but the
conditions
numbers eight to nine uh heavily
restrict
um the validation of normies and also
insist on
uh works being carried out following
acoustic survey so that works those
works haven't actually been
have been done yet so obviously with the
grant
uh hopefully of a liquor license
um all of those conditions will will
trigger
and physical works will actually be
carried out along with the proper
acoustic validation by an acoustic
professional and
so from from where i'm sitting all the
points that have
been raised and are rather going to be
lesser
uh with the activity of this
predominantly as a restaurant
through um very strict and planning
controls and obviously
they are potentially planning
enforcement issues if there was ever a
breach
of um say the hours i
that the hours may have traded later
under temporary events but what this
new planning commission dated october
2019 gives
is um a a validation to
a different style of activity it much
reduces
the um the hours and days that a
restaurant can operate
and to be to be frank with you the um
you know the the the issue of kogit 19
with restaurants it's a much more
powerful activity than
than running a um a bar venue
um which obviously has all the
undesirable
activities that go with that as you can
probably imagine
so i wanted to just make the point
finally that um
that you know this could operate as a
kentucky fried chicken
uh restaurant with you know with no
permission from
the committee it's it's the sale of
alcohol the
the obviously the applicant is after in
order to
try and promote and encourage
long-term investment on the site as well
as the protection of a
great two-star heritage asset
i hope that's that that's okay with you
is that is anything else you'd like to
ask me
uh thank you mr moore um councillor and
councillor pickering do you have any
questions for mr moore
councillor pickering thank you chair
um i mean my points weren't about um
running at all um it was about the
implications of uh being granted a
license
and um the website says that it's room
as a wedding
venue and the party
and if they have a temporary events
license then that's a controlled
single event and towards the end of the
explanation that we've got if i'm
understanding it right
it's now to change from being a wedding
venue to a restaurant open to the public
not a closed event with a license to be
selling
alcohol either for consumption with
meals or without meals
um is that the case a
yes that is the case but there is
nothing to stop
um the restaurant being being booked um
as a as as a wedding in in a similar
manner to
le manoir or some other um locations in
restaurants around the country
so you know weddings and clothes type of
events would be
would be no different um you know
than operating as a restaurant because
it's still planning control there's
planning controls on noise
highways parking and all of the other
aspects
the only difference with a temporary
events notice is that
you know this cannot function um
as a restaurant on say monday tuesday
wednesday thursday
and obviously the hours are are
restricted under planning which
under under a temper events notice may
may be different
i think that you know the the subtlety
uh on
on the selling of the alcohol um you
know is
is is huge um but uh
you know to have a private 50th birthday
party
there is is no different to other
restaurants um
other than the sale of alcohol would be
um
would be possible
thank you oh council alone
you muted council alone
excuse me just a general question really
it's referred to
in the uh objections about
it being basically a country lane and
um so therefore what what do you feel
the impact would
actually be on the traffic the amount of
traffic
you think it would have a big impact on
that
um all i can say is that the amount of
traffic for a restaurant
is is controlled the number of covers
are are
controlled now to a hundred you could
have had 300 people
in that venue as a
as a bar uh if if a proportion of it was
stand up drinking
and so the so the actual amount of
coming
and going in vehicular terms should go
down as a restaurant
compared with the way it operated under
a temporary events notice
there are passing places on the lane and
derbyshire county highways
have supported the application they've
also surveyed and that the information
is online
the passing places on the lane and
obviously with it being a a restaurant
there is um more likelihood of people
uh nominating a driver so there's less
um
potential number of um of cars compared
with lots of taxis coming and going and
the sort of party venue that it might
have been for
for young people so i think that
that the issue of the coming and going
and
will also be um restricted over the days
of the week
and as you can imagine people go out for
sunday lunch so
that was factored in as well um in the
uh
derbyshire county highways support for
the
restaurant rather than the previous
venue
council bickering did you want to come
in again
thank you chair i mean the main point
for me was i just wanted to be clear
um that we're actually now talking about
a change of use for the premises along
with the
license from a private function
venue to somewhere that's now open to
the public
um you might have to book a table in a
restaurant
you don't have to book a table to turn
up for just general drinking purposes
which is what this license would
afford that opportunity
if i could respond chair by saying that
it is an
it is a restaurant a3 under the youth
classes order of the town and country
planning act
it's not a bar you can't walk in and
have a drink
under the restaurant planning commission
that's been granted and is going to be
operated under so it is not a bar
and it's not a um you know a stand-up
uh venue in the sense of the way it
operated under the temporary events
notice
the i don't want to say say that you
know that
a restaurant doesn't involve a certain
amount of alcohol and
stand-up drinking at a bar but you
cannot walk in
off the street and have a drink that is
the fundamental
difference between a3 and a4 under the
use classes order
thank you did the licensing officer
have any questions for mr moore
i don't have any questions at all thank
you
right um there isn't anybody else here
is there to
make representations just bear with me a
second chair someone is attempting to
join
right um i'm just wanting to find out
who they are but they seem to be having
difficulties
[Applause]
uh sorry it's uh darren rowley um
licensing officer
okay
right we'll now consider any closing
submissions does the licensing
licensing and enforcement office there
are any closing submissions to make
i think i've covered most of it already
um
the application is for um
a premises license to win to enable
alcohol sales
live music recorded music and late night
refreshments
and i've been to the hours with members
already
in principle the licensing officers
don't have any objection
it's already been operating under 10
prevent notice however
it's for members to consider the
application making the decision
based on the information in front of
them thank you okay
uh mr moore um do you have any closing
submissions to make
mr moore probably gone
he's mr moore is on mute at the moment
hello mr moore you're on mute
hello mr moore
sorry i i'm i'm with you now thank you
yep as you can see have you any closing
submissions to make
uh no thank you okay thank you
we'll now adjourn to consider the
application and we'll return shortly
to inform you of our decision on our
return thank you
thank you martin could you please turn
off a live stream please
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
okay chair everybody's back in the room
okay thank you
um the committee's made their decision
um which is going to be um given to you
by uh kevin chilito the
solicitor thank you thank you chair
um the committee have agreed that they
are going to grant the premises license
but they are going to include an
additional condition of license
that condition is that it will apply uh
so long as the premises is used
primarily
as a restaurant it's a condition that's
designed to enable you to use it
occasionally for other purposes
and other events but to ensure that at
no stage does the
main role and nature of the premise has
changed to something other than the
restaurant
so that's the decision you
will receive a written notice of that
decision in due course
if you are if any parties uh including
the objectives are unhappy with the
outcome
then they will have 21 days to object to
the local magistrates court in
chesterfield
if unhappy with the license as granted
thank you thank you very much all thank
you
hey so mr moore mr todd if you'd like to
leave off now or alternatively you can
stay
thank you i like you bye-bye thank you
i'm now going to call for a two-minute
two or three minute break
that's okay with everybody
thank you chad
bobby report of the licensing team
leader
the shop we will now consider the second
application on today's agenda
can i please ask the licensing and
enforcement officer
to present report number ltl
forward slash zero three forward slash
two zero dash two one forward slash
kr to the subcommittee in respect of the
application
for the shop
good morning again chair and members
this report
is considered an application that was
received on the 3rd of september
for a business premises at 99 main road
sherland and the application was from mr
javed asgar
and it relates to the shop
key element to the application is that
the application states
that the general in the general
description of the premises is to be
for a convenience store with local
produced
craft products with the ability for
people to sample and taste
cask ale cyber spirits and alcohol that
are available for off sale
whilst on the premises and that will
include an
ever evolving range of local products
and artisan products
the applicant sees seeks to apply
for the following licenseable activities
and opening times
is for the sale of alcohol on and off
the premises
monday to sunday 8 a.m till midnight
with opening times of 8 a.m to midnight
all in the advertising of the
application we received a five
representations from members of the
public
two of those representations were
rejected by myself
following legal advice on the grounds
that they didn't meet the licensing
objectives
and therefore do not fall part of this
report
the remaining three were accepted as
being valid
and these representations are attached
to appendix
two three and four today again i'm quite
happy to go through
um those appendices for members if they
wish
when i get further on in the report
councillor bowman would you like
councillor would you like them to be
read out again
yeah just a brief outline please um
all right thank you kevin thank you
chair um
following the applicant's consultation
with training standards during the
application process the application has
agreed additional conditions
a copy of those additional agreed
conditions that members may wish to
incorporate into the license
are within appendix 5 of this
application
the police have confirmed that they do
not have any representations to make in
respect of this application
and options available for members are
that they can grant the license
they can grant the license with
additional conditions as members feel
fit or they can refuse the application
yeah if you just bear with me while i
move to the representations in the
reports
right the first representation is from s
goodwin and a smith and i don't believe
they're present today
and what they say is they wish to make a
representation regarding the application
for a premises license
relating to the sale or supply of
alcohol from on and off sales of the
premises
they live at 2 part lane sherland which
is located
next door to the shop on the right
separated by a small passageway
and they would like to object on the
following grounds prevention of public
nuisance
the hours proposed of atm till midnight
monday to sunday
are not compatible with this residential
location
and any late night noise from customers
traveling by car
or on foot to the shop will have the
effect of disturbing neighbors whose
bedrooms are mostly located
on the main roadside of the houses these
houses are mainly
19th century brick terraces which are
directly onto
the pavement these hours also
increase the possibility of nuisance
from customers who want to purchase
alcohol on their way home from local
pubs after closing time
we already experienced problems of
disturbance from people walking home
talking loudly and even urinating in the
passageway next to the houses
and we believe if the shop is serving
alcohol until
midnight this would increase these
problems we're also concerned the
wording of the application when it comes
to consumption of alcohol on the
premises
the intention in the application is to
cause customers to sample
produce before they purchase but we
would not want this to constitute
permission
for on drinking for other purposes in
the future
there is already four public houses
within a short distance of
the shop the second
representation has been submitted by
the um governess
of sorry by the clerk of the governors
to shill the primary school
and what they say is this submission is
made on behalf of the governing body of
sherlock primary school
in respect of the licensing application
this application was discussed in some
detail by the governments at their board
meeting
on the 29th the premises are immediately
adjacent to residential properties
giving rise to the possible occurrence
of public nuisance
when considering that the proposed
opening hours of the sale of article
are from 8 am to midnight every day of
the week
this will coincide with the school being
open for children arriving and leaving
the school site
the government's governor's fault that
such an approval at this time
will be counter to the current kobe 19
regulations
and could lead to anti-social behavior
littering
etc in the vicinity of the premises
there is an issue with this currently
with litter and other items being dumped
into
the landscaping on the boundary of the
school as well as the church
stroke school boundary governor's fault
that this would
be exactly exacerbated by the
availability of alcohol across such an
extended period of time
children's school is is close to the
premises
and the section of main road which is
the location of these premises
gets very busy and congested when
parents are dropping off and picking up
their children from school
the rear of the proposed license
premises is directly opposite the school
gate
and zigzag lines and this could lead to
difficulties when deliveries are being
made
these would inevitably be safety issues
with both children parents and the
general public
the governor has worked hard to make
safety paramount in the area of our
school
the main objective is to protect the
children from harm
at any time the responsibility which the
governor's
discharge diligently and one that does
not stop at the school game for these
reasons we will
suggest respectfully that this is not an
ideal site or area for an additional
licensed premises
chair there is then a third
representation
which is submitted by mr and mrs howarth
of main road in sherland i will briefly
touch on this
representation however i am conscious
that
mrs howarth is actually at the meeting
today
and will expand all this in due course
okay so in relation to the prevention of
crime and disorder
they're concerned of group people coming
out of the premises throwing bottles
between generally rounding
beetles parked in the street in the
residential area
in relation to public self-day sorry
public safety
and she says my neighbors myself and my
neighbors take our dogs out to 10
p.m and the thought of additional
intoxicated people lightering in the
area at this time
does not make me feel safe the
prevention of public nuisance
they're concerned about loud noise
bottles crisp packets and
waste being discarded in the street
the protection of children from harm
says there is a promise fall
over the road from the intended venue
alcohol and children do not mix
and then she's gone on to say for in the
further details there is the miners
welfare
and the hay hotel approximately 200
yards from this venue
and the redline public car public house
approximately 500 yards away in the
other direction
as it is we get some noise parking
disruption if there is an event on
the hay or the welfare we can live
without an additional drinking
establishment in what is otherwise a
quiet village okay
that's all i've got for you at this
point in time thank you
thank you thank you uh the councillor
bone or councillor pickering have any
questions for the licensing
team leader
the only thing i'd like to ask kevin is
um
are we talking micro pub or off license
or both
okay that's probably a question for mr
asgar
when he gets to him making his
submissions however my
understanding from the application is
that this will be
purely a retail shop
however it will offer samples to
customers
when they are buying alcoholic beverages
so that they can taste
before they buy and it may be if
members were minded to grant the
application in due course
they may want to consider conditions
around
that possibly relating to no seating
inside the premises or limiting the
testing to where people are intending to
purchase
alcohol as an off sale thank you jeff
thank you
um does mr mrs howarth um oh sorry
councilwoman
oh just very quickly um can i just
confirm then that we're talking
opening times until midnight
okay yes we are the application is from
8 am until midnight
thank
you know obviously there is a option in
there for members
um if they're not happy about those
hours to consider different towers
um as part of the consideration of the
application
thank you thank you thank you did mr mrs
howarth
um have any questions for the licensing
team leader
no okay thank you
uh does the applicant have any questions
to ask the licensing officer
no okay thank you right
um mrs house if you'd like to speak
thank you uh if it is purely going to be
a retail outlet then we've got no
objections at all
if it is going to be a license is going
to be granted
and then it's going to be the use will
be changed to a micro brewery
or a cafe
kind of idea selling alcohol then we do
object
and it's for the grounds that i've said
it's the noise it's the banging of the
car doors it's a residential area
we have enough alcoholic establishments
around here
we don't particularly want one two doors
down from where we live
and there's also the school to consider
with the children in close proximity
but if it's purely going to be a shop
for off sales
that's fine what i would like to ask is
on the
drawings that we received all the
counters are movable
which i understand could be for cleaning
whatever
but there's also massive void in the
middle of the shop
which could be set aside for tables
i'd like to know what the middle bits
for
uh mrs howarth would you like to um turn
on your camera
yeah thank you thank you sorry
all right um it's is um
is the applicant available to answer mrs
howard's question on the
mr ashkar are you there i am yes could
you turn on your camera as well sir
um how do you do that um
good point there should be a little um
two pictures of a microphone
and something which looks like uh a
camera which says start video
yeah and there's a line through it so if
you click on that that should do it
it's not essentially if you can't though
it's uh saying it's unable to detect a
camera
so uh well there is a there is a camera
connected to this
piece but if it's not essential then i
can still
okay thank you hear me yes yes we can
certainly hear you sir
okay so hello chair my name is david
asghan i'm the applicant for this
uh proposal that you're considering um
if you'd like me to go
from the very beginning of the
application or whether you'd like me to
answer
if you can just just at this stage if
you can just answer mrs howell's
question
please um the reason that we've applied
for off license as well as unlicensed is
that
purely and simply as a matter of law if
anybody was to consume any alcohol on
the premises
prior to purchase if we didn't have such
a license
that we would be breaking the law
everything is movable in the shop
because most retail fittings are
if we were to show any seating that
would have been a condition of this
application
um we consulted with the police the
trading standards
and north east alberta licensing
department and
i did speak to mr and mrs howarth prior
to submitting it and wasn't aware that
there were any
um issues that they needed to discuss
with me personally
with the application so i was somewhat
shocked when i did receive the letters
of objection
um but that's the democratic right and
it's um if you would like me to mitigate
anything that they're meant to be in
their
um objectives that i can um
if i was wanting a license for a micro
pub
after having 30 years experience in the
license industry and hospitality
then that's what i would have applied
for um we currently own and run
the hay hotel which is less than 200
yards away
the current corvid 19 pandemic has
decimated the hospitality industry so
with this project which was purchased
and
started in the middle of the pandemic we
had to look out of the box and look at
how
people's needs have changed um and
with it being practically impossible to
compete
with the likes of sainsbury's tescos
aldi and little
to make the business financially viable
we had to find a niche in the market
that didn't exist and hence the reason
for the
going back to the basics of the way that
off-licence and unlicensed premises
existed years ago
where bulk containers of alcohol were
purchased
and then decanted into the customers
containers for them to take home
at their leisure um being aware of the
obligations that we have as licensees to
offer even a free sample of that would
be breaking the law and hence the reason
for this
application if we want to have a cafe
restaurant micro cup we would submit a
license
to that nature in the application and
state that is what we wanted to do
okay thank you thank you for now miss
drago i'm just going back to mrs howarth
um do members have any questions uh for
mrs howarth
no do licensing officers have any
questions mrs howars
yeah i don't have any questions at all
at this stage
right okay thank you mrs howarth um
is there anything else you want to add
no
okay thank you back to you then miss
trago
um would you like me to go through the
first objection first put some appendix
to or
what would you like me to do now
whatever you just that's fine
so the first objective that we had which
was from solana goodwin
um was regarding her concerns about the
noise and disturbance that you think
envisages such a business would
include so we did correspond with each
other and
we informed them of the fact that we
have licensing requirements
to make sure that there's no nuisance to
the neighbors anyway
and also that if there's any existing
problems we can't mitigate those
but the fact that we're going to be
adding cctv that's recording
is normally a good barrier for people to
urinate in passageways because the last
thing they want to do is
um be seen doing that but i can't
envisage that this
application and the business as a whole
would increase any of the
reasons that they're put in their
objection
do members have any questions for the
applicant counselor bone
um yes could i ask um
coming from a village myself but
probably um a larger village than we're
talking about
can you tell me how many residents there
are in the village
approximately is that is that to me
yes um i'd say approximately there's
probably over 2
600 residents that live in the parish
but the actual location
is on a busy main road which is a
through fair between alfred
and clay cross and if you used to look
at the
availability of a similar retail outlet
within a 10 mile radius that you might
find
some similar as cruise farm shop which
is in the field
um but nothing any closer um the a61 is
an extremely busy road
passing traffic uh it's a good commuter
belt um
and hence when doing the demographics
and the feasibility of the project
it was a prime location
council vote can i can i comment on on
what i'm leading
into um in our village we've got just
over 11 000 people
we do have three off licenses and it
really concerns me
about this midnight closing um in our
village
um they usually close about hubs 9 10
o'clock
which is obviously much more sensible
so can i ask the applicant
why 12 o'clock
are people not able to if they do want
something from an off license
they know what time it closes and they
will go and get it
um so why 12 o'clock every night
when people are wanting to get to bed
and and they do generate a noise
i know a couple of hours you have the
youths hanging outside and
whatever but 12 o'clock at midnight
seems very extreme to me
the hours have been chosen purely and
simply under
the fact that not everybody works on a
nine-to-five basis
so if you look at the actual industry
that's local to the area
and the people who live there and work
there the majority of them work on
either three shifts
or revolving shift patterns and
for that reason some may be working from
six o'clock in the morning
um until two o'clock in the afternoon
some come two o'clock till eight o'clock
and then others don't eight till the
early hours of the morning um
i think the days of being able to
specify when people can
shop and when they cannot shop um
especially with the current pandemic
that we're in
and the restriction that the government
have posed on the hospitality industry
um it would be now in the
financial
basis of the business to actually make a
profit and
the other thing that you'd have to
mitigate in that respect is that
would you choose to open till midnight
well if you choose to open until
midnight is because there's an actual
demand for it if there's no demand for
that business
then you wouldn't open till that time i
think
i think mr agar i'd i'd disagree with
that because we already have an off
license which closes at nine
and i'm pretty certain if there was
business there
they would open um i can't speak for
that business
counselor bickering thank you chair and
i've got um a couple of
questions um and one of them is
relating to the question that counselor
bone asked
um and see i don't think that's a very
satisfactory answer mr hasgar and i'd
like to know what kind of research
you've done or evidence you've got
um that indicates that people in shirley
need a convenience
store that opens while midnight um
and you know if you're a convenience
store that sells
alcohol i could understand that you keep
relating to the hospitality industry
the convenience store isn't part of the
hospitality industry
so i'd like to know what evidence or
research you've done that indicates why
surely needs a convenience store that
opens until
and the second question i'd like to ask
is
um what size samples do you have in mind
is it about 10 milliliters that wets
your lips to give you a flavor
or is it a pint or two pints or a pub
measure of whiskey
or a pub measure of um so
what do you mean by sample please
um which part would you like me to
answer first
i'd like you to answer both of them you
can do them in either order
okay so the first part is why do people
need a convenience store
that's open well currently children
itself doesn't have a convenience store
all the local businesses that did
provide convenience or newspapers are
closed the closest one being at high end
saying briefs to go has currently opened
at the petrol station which is at the
bottom of the hill
um and opens for considerable a
considerably longer time
um the purpose of providing samples is
for people to taste the product
not to consume it on the premises to the
point of a pint two pints
or a measure because you're giving that
product away people you know it's uh
you're not
asking people to pay for it and for that
purpose
obviously you wouldn't be giving away a
pint or two pints or even a third of a
pint
um to quantify
an amount um if you were to come in and
want to purchase some rail it'd be
enough for you to wet your pallet and
savour it
um if it was a artisan gin then you just
probably won't have a little sniffer
smell of it and just well it'd be less
than 10 mil because you couldn't afford
to give it away free
you know the need is to get people in
there to try it
to buy it not to sit there and drink it
and
it's going back to the hospitality
industry um the reason i keep mentioning
that is because
because of this current kobe 19 pandemic
it has been decimated and you have to
think out of the box in what people are
doing now
which is buying beer and products to
take home and not go to the pub because
they don't feel safe doing so
mr agar can i just um bring an issue
over you just
you just said the the nearest off
license was in haim
that is incorrect it is sherland post
office
that is sherland and you did mention the
parish when you were talking about
numbers
you mentioned the parish of sherland the
parish of sherland
includes haim but actually sherland post
office
is the off licence and that is actually
sure and not high in there
councillor bone um
i know it sounds as i've got a beer in
my bonnet about this midnight closing
um but you're saying that um obviously
you need to let's say make money because
of what's been happening with covered
if you were to be allowed a license
until 12 o'clock what would your
staffing arrangements would be because
i personally would say you need more
than one person
in the shop if you're going to be open
to that time because my experience
is you're going to have undesirable
shall we say coming into
the off license between 11 and 12
o'clock
um are you geared up to be able to
handle that
we're getting to be able to handle that
purely and simply because of the
continuous cctv and monitoring that we
have on site
anyway and it's paramount that the staff
has saved whilst they're working there
um the desirables that you mentioned
will probably go out earlier in the day
and buy a cheaper version of alcohol
from one of the supermarkets
rather than come and pay a premium price
and
going back to the chairs comment about
the
nearly stop license i always might
incorrect for me to assume
as it's called high-end village stores i
thought it was high-end um
but it's still some considerable walking
distance away it's not within
um a short walk
is anything else you'd like me to answer
do the licensing officers have any
questions for the applicant
yeah um i've got two questions which
may assist members when they're
undertaking the deliberations
um mr um
would you have any objections if the
committee
added a condition relating to
um no seating and tables to be provided
on the premises for customers
i have no objection to that whatsoever
thank you
and secondly if members weren't
happy with the midnight closing
um would you be prepared
to consider a earlier time for closing
thank you without knowing what that time
would be it's hard for me to consider it
oh thank you
thanks chair mrs howard have you any
questions for the applicant
no i think uh yeah could i uh
just intervene and ask a couple of
follow-up questions
you can
go ahead thank you uh mr askgar uh just
a couple of quick questions
do you have any idea of roughly what
proportion of your sales will be made up
of alcohol
um i said probably 25 to 30 percent
thank you um and the
other question can i just check have you
got all the
relevant planning permissions and
everything in place yet for use as
a convenience store yes because it has
the correct usage
um the ironic thing is that this
property started off life in sherland
as the sherlin cooperative convenience
store
and had an alcohol license at the time
um
with very little restrictions and over
the years it's had various changes
abuses from being a bakers to being
a hairdresser as a beauty therapist
um this application was
put forward as that is the most feasible
business plan that i have in mind for
that property there may be somebody that
might come along and say well we want to
change what you do
but for them anybody to change anything
they would have to come back in front of
this panel
they would have to submit a new
application and it's impossible for me
to
envisage what might happen in 10 years
time but i can tell you what my business
plan is and the business plan if it was
to be a micro pub
or to allow people to congregate to
drink alcohol
then i would apply for purely a on
license
for that purpose um i have no qualms in
doing that if that was
the business plan that i wanted to run
thank you
thank you
right we'll now consider any closing
statements
do their licensing officers have any
closing submissions to make
jeff from a licensing point of view
obviously
you've heard that the application is
from 8 a.m till
midnight seven days a week it relates to
um on and off sales of alcohol
for a convenience store um
trading standards have already agreed a
number of
draft conditions which have been added
into the operating schedule
or red day if members were minded to
group the license and i would ask for
them to be included
and other than that i've got no comments
to add at this stage thank you
come slowly get your mute
sorry about that mrs howard have you any
final questions or submissions
now just concerned about the hours and
if it is going to be sort of drinking
done
but if it's going to be a sharp then now
all right thank you
mr agor have you any closing submissions
um yes i have actually um to answer mrs
howard's statement about whether it's
going to be a drinking den
um if that had been the intention in any
way shape or form
that would have been the application
that with all due respect you would have
been looking at now
we haven't held back any information
we've had candy discussions with trading
standards
the police and the licensing department
and
put this proposal forward in an honest
and fair way
and to answer her question about her
drinking then
that is if that's the only problem the
concern mrs howard has then he has no
concern for that because
that is not its intention um
other than that i'll leave it in your
hands it's your decision what you decide
to do
thank you we'll now adjourn to consider
the application and we'll return shortly
to inform you of our decision
thank you thank you
martin if you could just pause the feed
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay that's everyone back in the room
chair all right thank you
we've made our decision uh the
committee's made the decision
and we'd like um kevin charlito the
solicitor
to um read it out please thank you
thank you jeff um
just bear with me because there are a
number of things i need to just run
through
the first is that the license will be
granted however it will be granted
subject to some
amendments the first of which
is that the committee are not going to
approve
sales for consumption on the premises
um there are limited circumstances in
which free samples can be provided
without a premises license
and i suggest mr asghar goes away and
looks at those rules
and if he is going to provide free
samples operates very carefully within
them
um the second amendment is that the
committee have uh chosen to
limit opening hours to 10 pm
and then there's three other conditions
that they wish to impose on the license
the first is that there'll be no seating
for customers in the premises
the second is that the license holder
will provide
a litter bin outside the premises and
the third
is regular litter checks will be
undertaken
and it's disposed of in the immediate
vicinity of the premises
a written decision notice that sets all
of this out and the committee's
decision-making process will be supplied
to all parties
uh and upon receipt of that if anyone
wishes to appeal they can do so by
lodging an appeal at the local
magistrates court in chesterfield
within 21 days of that notice
thank you chair
thank you thank you thank you for all
your attendance today
um and i now declare the meeting closed
thank you bye
you